alright guys bang bang I've got Mike
here thanks for doing this man we live
we doing this yeah we're live let's go
are you ready I'm such a fangirl I
cannot believe I'm on your show this is
amazing I remember I met you and you're
just a little tiny little bloggers in
podcaster in my house and and you came
by and you have just you're all growing
up now and look at you now
so Mike knows that the secret of podcast
success is just lay the [ __ ] on real
early alright so for like the three
people Rose the ego for the three people
who are listening who don't know who you
are
give us a quick rundown of what you did
before getting into a crypto and okay I
thought you were gonna say for the three
people watching this podcast and I was
like wow that's I think you have a few
more than that how many people on
average watch your podcasts or all the
different ways in April's the last
numbers I remember 2.5 million people
2.6 million people total views and
downloads no no total for the month so
it varies like episode did with tomorrow
got a million views just on YouTube
alone he knows how to do a [ __ ] sound
byte or we lied to swear sorry he knows
how to do a sound byte doesn't he
so of course me rich man it's we tell
the truth
people pay attention right they do as
long as you say it with the right way
and the right way and he has that down
to a science so yeah he was marketer
originally so okay so me I what are you
I mean I'm known for TechCrunch which I
started in 2005 and sold in 2010 so I've
been away from TechCrunch for longer
than I was there but luckily the people
that took over have kept it going strong
and so it's still a known brand and
that's great for me and I go to the
conferences and and all that before that
I was an entrepreneur and I started well
I started off as a lawyer and then I
started companies and the first company
failed the second company was a mild six
it's actually a fascinating story about
venture capital which I'd be happy to
talk about and it was in the payment
space and then and I started a company
after company after company it either
failed or were mild successes and then I
started TechCrunch in 2005 because I was
I was living on the beach in Manhattan
Beach I was between jobs and I'm like I
need to like start researching more
because I I was sort of out of the loop
and I realized there is no website that
like just talked about startups you know
it was like there were there were tech
sites like seen it that talked about
startups with a lot of other stuff but
nobody was focused just on startups I
thought this this group of people needs
a needs a place to call home and and
there was no real social media back then
or anything like that and so I just
started TechCrunch on as a lark and a
lark as a hobby and and it took off it
was like the one startup I didn't
intentionally start as a startup and it
was it was the company that that that
first made me some money and so and
that's it after that I became a venture
capitalist and I switched into crypto
and so we started TechCrunch it was just
you writing it was basically like almost
like a beefed up blog really right and
then it kind of grew from there into
what we know it today yeah you can
actually go back and find the first
posts that were terrible and it was me
sitting in my bathing suit on the beach
in Manhattan Beach I surfed every day my
life consisted of getting up surfing
playing video games for like six hours
or more girlfriend come home yell at me
for being a total slob and then I would
start writing and and that was it and so
I did that for a few months and then it
took off like I said so I was able to
start getting other writers started
getting some revenue we've had some
innovative ways of making money back
then and at the end it was like
40-something people we were in a house
in Atherton which is in the middle of
Silicon Valley and a crappy rental house
in the in the richest ZIP code in
America there's a tear down house and we
had interns in our backyard on Archaea
desks the first thing you had to do as
an intern was build your own IKEA desk
and then they were in the back yard with
extension cords running out and their
laptops and like they're trying to shade
the Sun and look at their laptops and
get work done and finally the city came
to shut us down and after
that we became more corporate we got an
office and started doing things normally
but the best thing I did I did with
TechCrunch is I never took venture
capital why like all of my competitors
the ones that did well and didn't do
well they all took venture capital so
even the ones that sold for a lot of
money
the founders made nothing or next to
nothing because I had learned I remember
I told you I had this first startup it
was called HX it was a payment startup
and we sold it to first day that
corporation twelve months after we
founded it for like 32 or 33 million
dollars and you think wow I was there a
couple founders of me and we thought
we'd make money right we didn't and
here's why we we raised 18 million in
venture capital from draper fisher
Jurvetson back then 2x liquidation
preferences were considered normal now
it's 1 X and so that meant that the VC's
got two times their money back before
anyone else took any money and and two
times 18 is more than the purchase price
so to not block it they had to pay us
off and I basically had enough money to
buy a nice car and that was it and I
learned being an entrepreneur is great
but being a VC is much better if you
want to actually make money so if you
take money in TechCrunch when you didn't
take the money
how did that change the way you build
the company we had to run it from
revenue and so you know one of the
things about venture capital is you can
raise all this money and you don't
actually have to know if your product
fits you know the idea is you're
spending money to build a product and
then hoping people will come if you
don't have that luxury or decide not to
take it you have to find other ways to
fund that business and generally
traditionally that's through cash flow
and so we were constantly finding new
ways to make money through ads at first
and then eventually through conferences
yeah and I believe I've heard stories of
like literally founders trying to like
show up to the office to get stories is
that true or one just in fact that one
of the really innovative ways they came
up with making money is we had a webcam
in the office it's on all the time at
least I think it was on 24/7
we had a whiteboard and Heather our CEO
who's my partner now still would write
the name of the startup on the
whiteboard
put the whiteboard like in front of the
camera and she charged like thousands of
dollars for that for a day and I mean we
did that for like months and made lots
of money like it helped us get through a
rough period I think you know eight or
whatever but anyway yeah people would
come it was sort of a rite of passage to
come and show up the techcrunch and it
was fine sometimes it got weird like
some Dutch guys the founders of the next
web which is now a pretty well-known
website and nice enough guys but they
they they had a startup and they decided
they had to get into TechCrunch and so
they they broke into my house while I
was sleeping and they came and like open
my bedroom door and they had a video
camera and they filmed me and I had to
start a Starbucks they got me a
Starbucks and they filmed me like in bed
waking up and boy was I pissed I mean I
was I was very pissed and I remember
Wired magazine wrote it wrote an article
about it as life it was like the most
hilarious thing in the world like it's
just I'm thinking like I mean they
committed a crime right but it was like
so I had I had no privacy and so
sometimes I had to leave the TechCrunch
house and go other places just so I
could you know get away from it all yeah
that's absolutely nuts if you were to
start TechCrunch today and like really
go hard into media as an entrepreneur
what would you do differently or how do
you kind of see that the difference what
so I mean I know the answer I trying to
think of an interesting way of saying it
so again when I started TechCrunch there
was no place for startups they weren't
very newsworthy particularly very young
startups got no nothing no news
whatsoever until they raised money at
least
and as TechCrunch grew we still covered
startups but we found that like big
store like I broke the YouTube getting
acquired by Google I broke it before
anyone else and had the price that
actually put TechCrunch on the map and
then you know we started doing google
stories and Facebook stories and big
company stories got a lot more traffic
and so you start to gravitate towards
the big news and that's also why seen it
and others do that and so today
TechCrunch is largely big company news
sometimes it's regurgitating press
releases and a lot of social justice
stuff some of which is awesome and some
of which is just terrible and so I
actually think the original idea for
TechCrunch is
still needed and you've seen different
companies and products like coming to
existence over the years to deal with
that's like product UNK was one if you
remember product time which is still
going so I actually think the original
thesis is actually still a good one
and I think if somebody wanted to do
that I think there would be an audience
because there's this there's an
ecosystem of young founders who who need
press and and they have interesting
stories to tell I would never do it
again it was too it was just too
difficult it's too much work for not
enough money ultimately but I think in
crypto which is the understanding now
like we desperately need this I crypt
the crypto news news ecosystem is not
healthy and and I think that somebody if
they wanted to could do this but not me
so do you think that it's a store
written thing where it's kind of
websites mobile optimized whatever do
you think there's video audio whatever
other mediums make more sense I think
video makes a lot of sense I think video
is hard like you know as you know you
know you can talk forever but it's not
necessarily interesting you need to edit
it you need to produce it you need to
have studio it's just a lot of work and
some people don't want to consume
content that way because they it you
know creates externalities around you
you've got noise and stuff like that I
like reading a good article so I think
text is always going to be very
important I think obviously videos and
audio is hugely important as well yeah
it's interesting and then we started did
you've seen you can build alike you can
you can build an empire with you know
just doing what you're doing when you're
kids in your kitchen where are you you
know I'm in my kitchen right now we used
to have an office and basically just
took one room and did it there but I
mean look there's no one way to do it
right it's just you have to find
interesting content and and really love
what you do and I think you'll be
successful then I also think the the
whole idea of venture capital there's a
lot of venture capitalists who are still
confused that a pure play media company
is going to be you know a billion dollar
company and I think what we're learning
now just like you figured out hey look
the conferences the webcam ik these
other revenue sources can be highly
for what they are now we're gonna get
into this world where like the media
companies figure out other ways to
monetize than just like hey pay me some
advertising and I'll slap a you know
banner ad somewhere or whatever and what
I haven't seen yet that I think BuzzFeed
maybe tried to do this is I'm shocked no
one's built a media company and then
went and built products and then use
their distribution to pipe the products
through yeah I think BuzzFeed tried it
but I don't know how successful it was
I'll tell you one thing ultimately I
don't care okay I mean I don't think a
lot about how to build the next media
empire and I think that's why I was
successful I truly loved like what I did
like the very first few years I didn't I
didn't think about the business Heather
did I mean I talked about the business
although that was all my CEO so I hired
a CEO because I'm terrible at managing
people she ran the business she turned
him into what it was I was just I don't
say I'm the talent it sounds like I'm
boasting but I was literally just a guy
who very important call coming I was
literally just a guy who wrote content
every day I loved meeting founders I
loved meeting understanding what their
new products were and that's just what I
love doing and I think obviously you
love what you're doing right I mean you
like talking to people so you obviously
spent a bunch of time interviewing
founders hundreds if not thousands of
them how'd that help you when you got to
the investing side of the table um a lot
of people owed me favors right I mean
you know for an entrepreneur that first
press is very important it's it can help
you hire it's your parents get to see it
your friends get to see it like it feels
good it feels more real and I was often
it's not usually the first person to
write about a start-up and so that
generates a lot of camaraderie and
goodwill and and so that definitely
helped when we launched our venture fund
get into some of the early like really
important deals that really helped our
first venture fund like hit it out of
the park and so you know it's it's also
just
doing good we'll get doing nice things
for people without any kind of
transactional hope for a payoff is
actually like really works out well in
the end right you just do what you love
you help people and you're going to find
a way to be successful from that and and
if it's not a transaction like some
people are so obviously transactional in
the way they deal with people that you
know what I mean by that you just sort
of end up being turned off by it all
just tell people like in a way that is
fun to do and it'll end up working out
it's funny too because I think Silicon
Valley like literally the physical place
more so than probably anywhere else in
the business world understands that and
I think it's like no ball talks about
you know playing long-term games
long-term people or whatever the quote
is and it just feels like Silicon Valley
has known this for decades and people
know they're to run into each other
again and so people generally try to you
said to the Venge
so let's just explore that per minute I
mean I think it's really important so it
I rely realized once I got into crypto
that that is not how the whole world
works
so in Silicon Valley we dealt with a lot
of New York people and your people have
their own special way of dealing with
people in business and not necessarily
negative you decide to be abrupt direct
right and you have to adjust to that
and New York people adjusted Silicon
Valley people but generally speaking
like people find a way in Silicon Valley
to work out their problems without like
it getting ugly I don't think no
benchmark sued uber a few years ago that
was like a sea change in Silicon Valley
like you just didn't see that I mean you
saw it very rarely with egregious
examples of malfeasance but like what
uber did like it was it was it was
interesting that benchmark sued them
because that reputational issue is
important to them when I got into crypto
I realized very suddenly that like a lot
of players were not in Silicon Valley or
New York they were in Europe and they
were in Asia and like completely
different like cultures right and if for
anybody who spends a lot of time in Asia
you realize how different the cultures
in Asia are but like when you deal with
people from China Chinese nationals you
have to like worry about things in a
certain way when you deal with people
from Singapore who are maybe Chinese
it's totally different Hong Kong again
totally different in Korea totally
different and so I had to learn very
quickly that people do business
differently and you have to watch
yourself because long-term reputations
didn't matter as much especially like 18
when we first started getting involved
in this in 2017 and it's a really a
problem in crypto because I think a lot
of people have almost like a Napoleon
complex I don't know how to put it but
like crypto was so hot in 2017 and it's
become so mundane since then and people
like you and I believe it will become
very very hot again but in the meantime
I think people with these very large
egos aren't making any money and they
act in a certain way that's just been
disappointing to me yeah and I think
also you see this in finance right etc
is just like it's a very binary game
kind of zero-sum I win you yeah and I
think also venture investing in general
like people who understand how it works
realize it doesn't have to be zero-sum
right yes maybe you lose it's not
zero-sum yeah yeah yeah and so I think
that like just the asset and the way
that the investing is done definitely
helps but on top of that also if you
think of Silicon Valley like there is a
scarcity of great companies right and so
everyone is going to when they see great
companies and whatever stack of the of
the process they're going to come I
would not say I'd say there's a surplus
of capital ok yeah yes either way it's
either surplus a capital or scarcity to
companies but there's a mismatch between
the capital available and the number of
companies that that they should probably
get that yeah right and that's not
that's probably not necessarily as true
in the finance world
maybe there's individual deals but it
there's definitely a very different
mindset without a doubt well and the
funny thing is you eventually gravitate
to people you like doing businesses so
you for example but who's our sponsor
today it's a block fire because why -
amazing companies yeah Mike is opposite
expert in all things media and revenue
but block by a great company you have
been you're an investor in and you've
been like from the beginning right
pretty early yeah yeah your fund has put
like a big bet on block flying over
multiple rounds and and you introduced
him to me and we invested because of you
and it wasn't you for example trying to
resell your shares to me at triple the
price that you bought them which is a
situation I recently came across with
some Asian investors with a different
company that I won't mention called
Arabic and it was just a wonderful and I
also I assume you didn't get a kickback
from block five as part of that which
another company we just looked at it
turned out somebody else is getting a
person introduced to us was getting a
kicker like all that stuff is just very
alien and ugly to me you simply liked
the company you thought I could add
value you thought it would be a good
investment for us you put us together we
made the investment and we love the
company and as far as I know you got
nothing out of that I hope except block
five was again even more appreciative to
you and I've never heard a company gush
over someone the way they gushed over
you when we first talked to them so
they're incredibly kind but but I think
that your point about it's this weird
thing where you're lining up incentives
right like I knew that we were super
bullish on the company we were literally
making a very big investment I knew that
they were looking specifically for
certain types of help that we said look
we can help in one area but there's
other people who are much better than we
are
let's go get those people you happen to
be one of those people who brought very
specific value to it to what they needed
and when you line that up I think the
point around you know one you get a see
a deal you didn't previously see or
didn't spend much time on right and you
like it so you're gonna do a deal they
look in and they say hey look we've got
this great investor being under our cap
table and for us it's one of these
things were like if you're not involved
in the deal like I would argue that the
deals upside potential is not as high as
it is with you in the deal right so what
yeah you you want people around the
table who you know can help because
those people will make everyone make
more money and also Nigro it's not fair
weather friends because because too many
people are fair
their friends nice eosin crypto as well
we're like when everything's hot you're
everybody's your best friend but
companies they really need their
investors when times are bad and if you
stick through a company when times are
bad they remember that and they tell
other people and and I'm not saying as
far as I know block fire hasn't had a
bad time yet but when they do you'll be
there for them and I'll be there for
them and and they'll remember that so
couldn't agree more
speaking of crypto stuff like I know
that you have I think used to have it
pinned to the top of your twitter
account buying bitcoins 2014 which was
not necessarily a popular thing to do
remember the first time you ever came
across Bitcoin or kind of what drove you
to it when when was the first time you
bought Bitcoin uh I think in early 60 I
heard about it in 14 when I Facebook and
I did nothing I didn't Google it and I
think the first time I bought it was
either end of 15 or beginning of 16 so I
had heard about it earlier and obviously
should have bought in Silicon Valley it
was just known right it was known what
it was but no one really had gotten
their arms around it her treated it very
seriously I say no one some people had
but not me
coin base I think coinbase was launched
around then I'm not sure yeah I think it
was like 13 or 14 and and it obviously
Silicon Valley startup and so I think
people started to understand it more and
and I'm I'm pretty sure the first crypto
I bought was on coinbase so I started an
account and and so it was it like some
and it was more just like hey let's see
what this is
right then hey I'm going to go all-in so
I bought some and then I forgot about it
and I mean I literally like quite in log
into coin base for years except I had
set up like an auto buyer or something I
thought it was anyway when I finally
logged in in like 17 I was looking at it
again I was like holy [ __ ] like this is
like this is some incredible like amount
of money alright compared to what I
first put in and so that was fun and and
I did that with a couple like I bought
Manero I was doing dark web research and
forgot why it wasn't to buy guns or have
someone killed but I
I bought Manero to like buy something on
the dark web and I never bought anything
in the Monaro like I bought I don't know
is like a few hundred dollars of an
arrow and at some point I looked in 2017
it was like a hundred fifty thousand
dollars of Manero I had no wallet but
like the only trace of it I had was a
printed out like key so you know that
ended up in our phone too but yeah it
was more just serendipity than anything
else yeah and I guess at what point did
you realize like hey this isn't just by
a couple of tokens and like I came back
a couple years later and it's this huge
thing and more so like there is a
legitimate investment thesis that we can
go build a fund around and deploy
capital in kind of a sustainable
repeatable process you want the truth or
you want like the really awesome answer
that sounds make me look smart so I want
the true the truth is I went on a date
with the person who is currently my
fiancee and she had a startup that was
doing it was heavy into crypto and and
this is in like early 2017 and she was
planning an ICO and she's talking about
these ICS and I had heard of them but I
wasn't fully aware of like exactly what
was going on and and I'm like it sounds
like a pyramid scheme to me and she's
like no no no like there's actual
companies being built and so I invested
in a couple of I SEOs after that and as
you know in 2017 you couldn't I mean it
would be hard to not make money on ICS
in 2017 so you know I quickly made a lot
of money on those icos and and I said oh
I think I want to like do this more
full-time so I had a discussion with my
partner at the venture fund and he was
less interested in crypto so I decided
at that point to break away from the
venture fund but hidden continue to run
that and I would focus entirely on
crypto and and then you know I knew the
person I knew in crypto who had you know
the most interesting things going on was
with Brad darling house a triple and so
we had discussions about how I can
create a fund a hedge fund and he he
basically made it happen
ripple didn't invest they couldn't
protect reasons mostly but he helped
make it happen and I'll be eternally
grateful to him for that so it's really
because of a girl I guess is when I got
really into crypto
so I loved it and so when you go and
talk to Brad he's the CEO of ripple at
the time
yeah want a drink yes you pad up you
strategically put a box of troller paper
behind his head when you had them on
your podcast you can talk to Photoshop
something in and talk about this already
like if you're a real fan of pop you
know that was one of the like really
cool moments was when you strategically
purposely plays can't toilet paper
behind the CEO of ripples head on your
podcast it was brilliant marketing
especially spectacular all I will say is
that it's not true but you got it on
there good job oh no so when will you go
talk to him
and you specifically said hedge fund but
you guys do trading and you also do
venture like investments or is it all
more liquid trading so we're a hedge
fund and that's a structure and the
deviltry a hedge fund and a venture fund
is a venture fund gets a pile of money
and then spends it over four or five
years right you guys are a venture fund
right we are and then you raise new
funds every two years a hedge fund takes
pile of money and by the way when you
was a venture fund when you have wins
you then give the money back you to to
investors you don't reinvest it with a
hedge fund you get a pile of money and
you invest it over and over and over
again until investors say hey I'd like
to get my money back or part of it back
so it's more of a perpetual thing and
you get paid out every year that's a
great thing in a bear market like I
learned from a venture fund you start a
venture fund in seven to ten years you
get back a lot of money with a hedge
fund every year you get back a lot of
money unless you start a hedge fund the
first week of 2018 and and you're
basically barring Bitcoin it you know
not twenty thousand but I think fourteen
thousand and you're buying you know e
that a thousand you know you're gonna
see some lawson's out here and with a
hedge fund the promised losses is it's
very hard to recover from them so we
lost 42 percent of our fund in 2018 but
the market was down 90 percent in 2018
so we did okay like we fought in the
market the whole way and we peaked out
enough games mostly in deals we did to
do much better than the market even that
we you have to make that 42 percent back
before you could ever take profits and
the market still has it totally
covered from the highs of 2018 so all
the hedge funds that started that you're
in deep trouble some of them have gone
under some of them are actually have
gone under but they haven't officially
we were lucky enough that we had made we
had done better than the market so that
we raised its original thumbs like a
hundred million we raised another thirty
million dollars in December of 2008 from
our LPS and and because they trusted us
they liked us and we had done well
compared to the market and these are XRP
holders so we have done spectacularly
well against XRP so they loved us and
still loved us I hope that money in 2018
we then bought Bitcoin at like 3500 I
mean we had to buy something with it we
got a bunch of X RP as a contribution we
bought Bitcoin and then we just sat on
that so that ended up working out really
well so we had like a spectacular year
last year but we were very very lucky
because if we didn't have LPS that
supported us we would be I don't think
we'd be dead but we wouldn't be making
any money so yeah and at the I think
like end of q3 beginning q4 I wrote a
couple of times about this whole idea of
like the high-water mark in the hedge
fund world and I've actually been
surprised how many hedge funds have
survived right so you got you busines
explained like yeah there's two things
you can do either you can trade your way
out of it right and that's really really
good especially when you know double
digit losses or two you can raise new
capital and so I think that the raising
new capital that isn't subject to the
very hardcore mark yeah but more people
have done it right that new capital has
its own high-water mark so it's not it
doesn't go yeah it's every time you
raise new capital it's like you're
raising a new mini fund yeah go ahead
yeah and I think I was just surprised in
a positive way how many people were
either able to raise new capital or
trade their way out of it which i think
is overall you know net positive for for
the industry but there was a point there
in 2018 where people were down you know
I saw LP state Mississippi were down yet
more than the market right there down
literally 99 percent 98 percent well
it's yeah which is kind of the most you
can lose right like you can't lose 101
percent of your font and so being down
99 percent is
I mean it's almost epic like it's it's
like if you're gonna do it do it right
yeah cuz you basically what is it you
have to a hundred extra fun to get back
to the high-water mark yeah yeah well
you turn a million dollars into your
turn what is it a million dollars into
ten thousand dollars is that right and
if you've lost ninety nine percent of
the fund
well one hundred thousand turns into one
thousand that's math we can do and then
yeah which is difficult so even in
crypto that's hard to do it's it's it's
hard to do yeah so obviously a big piece
of the crypto industry is crypto
regulation I think it was back in 2018
there was there was a moment where I saw
you fire off a tweet and I said look I
don't know Mike super super well at the
time but I said I know he's mad because
you basically were like look like I
can't invest in the US if everything's
so pissed I could just tell I knew I
knew that there was that that we came
with like smoke coming out of your ears
as you sent it and now we're seeing
conversations about J Clayton
potentially not being a [ __ ]
Commissioner for for longer he's gonna
get a promotion too it's gonna be the US
District Attorney for the Southern
District of New York potentially is that
a promotion isn't a promotion I don't
know their articles I read position as a
promotion but that's a good point like
maybe that's just corporate element but
kind of how do you look at the
regulatory front today where IC o----
seem to kind of have dissipated in the
u.s. maybe we're seeing more
internationally but just how do you look
at the regulatory front
well I think the u.s. I'm older right I
remember the internet and the internet
was invented by America and spread first
in America and nobody messed around with
it legally and it grew like crazy and
now it drives the whole economy these
companies that were created in the 90s
right Google Amazon etc
cryptos different like crypto I'm not
exactly sure where crypto was invented
it doesn't matter like nobody knows but
wherever that what it was invented on
the Internet and the US has done like it
sometimes it ignores it and sometimes it
throws up roadblock but what it really
needs to do is just get out of the way
and like it did with the internet and it
did absolutely has it and so you know
there's so much innovation that wants to
come in crypto in the US and so many of
these entrepreneurs leave the US or
don't move here from wherever they live
and it's it's just I feel bad for the US
right I feel bad because I'm an American
I want our country to succeed and I
believe crypto is the future I believe
Bitcoin is money and money is Bitcoin
period and why would we not want to you
know I know why we don't want to like be
in the forefront of this and threatens
the dollar it's confusing and the sec
you know is always trying to protect
people from you know schemes but we need
to let innovation blossom and we don't
want that just to happen in China and
Singapore and etc because ultimately
it's back to the US so yeah I was mad
I'm still mad and I think that we need
to get somebody in in there that at the
very least provides regulations that are
understandable so we can work through
them as opposed to this great [ __ ]
unknown which means nobody does anything
in crypto in the US anymore
and you know that worries me so yeah and
it feels like the proposed solution from
what most people all cancer have common
sense just say hey look tell us what the
rules were though you're saying it's the
problem right now like the rules are
being written retro actively through
enforcement and not instead saying hey
here's the rules if I sprint are the
rules they'll go play by the rules you
know for the good actors it's just like
oh I did this thing now you're gonna
come after me because but I also have
like a letter from a lawyer that says
that this was legal and you just get
this weird weird yeah yeah no you can
hire you can hire Skadden arts and like
try to work it all out and in telegrams
case and it doesn't work out I know like
if you like I have somebody who does my
taxes for me and he does a lot of tech
people's taxes and the crypto stuff is
like he's very very good at what he does
but he's even he was making educated
guesses on how
I should pay taxes on my own crypto
gains over the years and what's up with
that like you know the just there's not
even clarity at that level and so yeah I
mean I hope at some point soon we get
our act together and you know recent
news suggests we might have a hope about
going outside the US where else and you
guys spent a lot of time I know you guys
in Asia but they're specific cities or
countries that are that are interesting
yeah I mean I mean Singapore is like the
meeting place in Asia it's sort of the
Silicon Valley of crypto and Asia and so
Singapore is the easy place to go
because everybody likes going to
Singapore it's for those of you haven't
been it's somewhere you definitely want
to go you know at least once as an
American I value freedom and personal
freedom Singapore doesn't have that and
so I was expecting a kind of a
Disneyland esque police state and that
is kind of what it is but it's pretty
pleasant like if you just want a nice
place to live that's safe it's a great
place to be
and it's interesting as an American to
have my some of my views challenged by
just visiting seeing how great it is
but Singapore is a place for a lot of
people me we spent a lot of time in
Japan and Hong Kong Korea and China as
well and those different places
countries or cities become more
interesting at different times but
Singapore is definitely sort of the
place to go if you want to have a taste
of crypto in Asia do you see like
different types of companies or projects
in Asia versus the United States or do
you think that kind of all of the
variations you get are being built in
both geographies I think if you ask most
crypto investors what they really think
they will tell you that most of the real
science being done in crypto is in the
US with caveats there's stuff in Israel
that's being done that's amazing
and there is actual science being done
in Asia but the u.s. I think is still
the leader in terms of where the actual
work is being done but a lot of these
companies aren't based in the US they
have employees here for example yeah and
is that a function of the capital mostly
being in the US or do you think that
that's just literally like Silicon
Valley has this institutional knowledge
they've got the muscle memory and so
people want to build companies in the US
because they
they've seen the most successful company
come from I don't know I'm not sure to
give an answer to that I mean I mean I
could imagine all kinds of prejudices as
well coming into it like subconsciously
I don't know why and there is definitely
good stuff being done around the world
and it just might be that we have a you
know we have a big tech you know infra
infrastructure here for people to spring
from but China does as well and it's
just a little different there for people
so yeah and so going outside of crypto
obviously the political landscape is
just pure chaos at the moment
we've got an autonomous zone in like six
or seven blocks of Seattle which I think
you're actually from from Washington I'm
near Seattle now yeah yeah that's fun
okay and then we've got my favorite
thing you've tweeted a while is please
don't take the Presidential Debates from
us because they forgot I used to be a
Marine right army yet did you oh so like
Marines are I won't get into that but
like just the army guy and you just want
to like like break up Chas or chop and
like just create order from chaos or
like how do you view that do laugh at it
this is gonna sound crazy but I am a big
believer in life that people self-select
into the communities they want to live
and so if people literally want to go
live in a place where there's no police
they do you know self policing or
whatever and whatever kind of all time
is doing they you have at least yeah we
have a guy of people being maced like
it's literally like it's yeah it's the
it's literally what happens when you
have an organized mafia but yeah when
you have a power vacuum what happens
like the I think they were calling the
one guy the warlord but like yeah the
mafia this different age for people but
like somebody takes over and is troll
yeah so like I'm actually the belief
like let people do whatever they want
maybe don't do in the downtown Seattle
like that seems kind of ridiculous where
that's like kind of pairs that paid for
it whatever but if people want to go do
that stuff like I'm sure there's other
weird places in America that aren't on
the front page of every news oh you can
do that well look I mean
the only problem I have with it really
is that people who own or live there who
didn't elect to become part of it were
just subsumed into it that's a problem
otherwise I just found it kind of
entertaining right I mean it was it was
uh it's the best marketing campaign
someone could run for having police
right like like that's the way I think
about it is like yeah I get the whole
like people want to defund the police
but the the argument that I've heard
actually to me that seems more
compelling and people freak out when
when they hear this about the
explanation but it's like no actually
should they should get more funding and
you should require rather than like six
weeks of training to become a police
officer like make them train for two
years treat like the Navy SEALs you
literally have to be at the top 1% of 1%
to get through this program and then you
get to you know you have the pleasure of
serving as a Navy SEAL well same thing
with the please and also take that
additional you know year and a half or
more of training and don't just treat
you know teach you how to shoot guns
like teach them how to do social worker
stuff for you know all these other
things that it's bad because like the
police are killing people that is a
problem
right you are we had that we have to ask
ourself like how much of it is like
police officers or bad people and how
much of it is like we've put them in a
bad position in terms of the way that we
train them actually turn them into like
you've actually been in combat - right
yep I mean my knowledge of combat is
based on video games and movies so I
have no idea but like being in an
environment can change you after a while
right for sure and I mean and so you
know being unlike being a police like I
remember to taking away from the police
I remember watch reading some like
article written by a fireman in San
Francisco a couple years ago and his job
was basically to basically try to
resuscitate drug addicts who Dover does
right I mean that's it it wasn't they
weren't putting out any fires all night
was spent trying to like you know revive
these people who were dying on the
streets and you know his his main goal
was to not like to wear enough
protective gear that he wouldn't get
like accidentally stabbed with a needle
right
all these palms are on that but they how
desensitized you get to human suffering
when you're when you're doing that and
so I assume police you know get
desensitized to certain things after a
while and and and that's why in their
mind planting drugs what you see more
more videos that it's a perfectly
reasonable thing to do because they know
that person's deep down as a bad person
so they're helping society by doing it
and and I don't know if more training
helps out or not I have no idea what
helps that so yeah and I think also part
of it is in many cases the police will
explain away the behavior in their head
whether they're right or wrong part of
what I think I said this is somebody
recently and I think they were a little
taken back that like this is the
mentality but like for example a lot of
military members across all of the
branches the military when they're at
war there's a saying that literally says
I would rather be judged by 12 than
carried by six it essentially is hey
look I'm not gonna die because then
basically that is the judge and
executioner right yeah I think the same
thing some of that mentality per is
pervasive in the police but what we have
to remember is like I don't care what
somebody does like you as a police
officer can't be the judge and
executioner
like if you kill somebody that is a
finite thing they don't ever get there
like day in court and when you lose that
part of the social fabric or like the
social contract of like innocent until
proven guilty and kind of all of those
things that I think Americans kind of
hang our hats on no well no one reason
was going to disagree with anything
you're saying and I think most of
America feels that way like we can
actually think police are sometimes way
too brutal and we can also think that a
lot of this protesting and looting is
absolutely ridiculous and has lost the
plot right you can think two things at
once like you want to fix a problem but
you don't want to tear down Western
civilization to solve that problem and
I don't know I don't know depicted yeah
it's look there are you agree with
everything you're saying there's people
way smarter than you and I who hopefully
will will come up with the solutions but
I think that people are starting to
understand like I think part of the
country wants a perpetual revolution
like they profit from it and they don't
want anything fixed and and that I'm a
libertarian I'm not I think Republicans
and Democrats are almost equally like
ridiculous but these cities have been
under Democrat control for decades if
they wanted something change they could
have changed it at any time including
now and yet you don't see a lot of
actual change so I'm not sure they want
I think that they I think they being
some in the political class you know
want this to be perpetual and on the
other side I think Chaz was probably
like one of the greatest political
assets for Trump that he had I mean the
longer that went on the more
ridiculousness around it the better for
him which is why I think you're seeing
it just being disbanded out of my
understanding but I'm not sure our
politicians want to fix anything in this
country I think they're all like getting
their piece I think they're all peeing
in the flowerbed and at some point the
flowers die and I'm not sure anybody's
trying to save the flowers anymore
do you think that I'll call it the
Silicon Valley ticket who the people are
probably don't matter nearly as much but
run through your favorite you know kind
of best-known most memorable people in
Silicon Valley if they got together and
said hey look we're gonna put not only a
presidential candidate forward but
literally an entire government so we're
gonna pick president vice president you
know all the way down a cabinet like
here is who you are going to vote all on
one single ticket and you know that
going into it and these are people who
are entrepreneurs they solve problems
they don't have allocate capital Bulevar
online do you think that that has
receptivity in kind of the non tech
world in America I don't think it's a
pointless question I believed I voted
for Obama and I believe Obama was gonna
bring this country together and it did
not he did not bring this country
together and some people think he tried
I think he died think for evidence shows
that he gave up on that I think a lot of
that even go for Trump but I think a lot
of people who did thought that he was
going to be a certain way and he has
like he just has it been even the things
he promised he hasn't been able to get
done I'm not sure any politician can
survive the political machine so I think
we need to rethink the whole way
politics works in America power the
federal government is immense and
unimaginable by our founders cannot
imagine that the power of the federal
government the power of lead in the
court system and activism of the courts
like we shouldn't care who the president
is
right and and I'm not sure that like we
should be hoping the Supreme Court is
going to solve every problem that
Congress can't get their act together
and work out and and so I don't know how
to solve it with a group of different
people being in power I'm just I'm just
not sure that there are perfect people
and in this and that's why you know do
you all start to think about getting a
place out of the u.s. like I sound
dramatic but like I own a house outside
of the US and I'm you know I have plans
to go there if things get bad enough
here yeah does like the response to the
pandemic was whether actually happened
or the perception of like hey the
federal government's gonna turn to the
states in the state governments you
solve this problem and we kind of saw a
lot of the state governments get exposed
for having just as poor leadership and
effectiveness as the federal government
look I think in February it was pretty
obvious we should have like told people
to wear masks and instead the government
was telling me people the opposite right
I mean masks seem to be not the Silver
Bullet but darn close if everybody wears
masks I think you really crushed the
spread of the virus and literally we
lied to the American people and told
them they were ineffective simply
because we didn't want people to rush
out and get all the masks and it turns
out there like any masks a bandana
actually provides you more protection
than you could have imagined and so no I
don't think we handled it properly and I
think now it's just politics people on
the right don't want to wear masks like
why and people on the left like it's
just so no and I don't think the federal
government is really set up to handle
these kinds of problems I think you know
talk about the police don't prevent
crime I mean they prevent crime for
their existence but they come in
afterwards and clean up the mess right
and so you know people who are Second
Amendment advocates like myself say you
know you need to protect yourself
because when you know when seconds count
you know the police are minutes away and
and the federal government also isn't
good at preventing this kind of stuff
like they're good at it like the federal
government's good at big monolithic
responses to things after they'd happen
to try to stop it but they're not good
at like this upcoming problem and how do
you deal with it part of the problem is
it's just a big organization right it's
hard to get pieces moving turning a
battleship the other problem is if you
do nothing you're probably better off
politically than if you do something and
it's wrong and so I'm just not sure
there's there's a solution other than
maybe don't lie to us so yeah and the
Second Amendment thing I think wouldn't
blew me away was just gun sales went
through the roof right man I gotta
follow all my liberal friends that
they've done with you there are people
you know who support every leftist cause
imaginable who have privately asked me
for gun advice at least five of them and
I've helped them get the right weapons
and I've also told them like if you
can't find a way to take a class and use
it safely like you know you're probably
worse off right cuz they're so
frightened of these things that they're
probably gonna end up hurting themselves
or not knowing what to do with them but
ya know it's sorry I interrupted you
know III think that's dead-on my buddy
literally said that he was a gun store
and the line was legitimately out the
door and he said I love seeing
minorities and women do it too
I love I love seeing minorities like
because a lot of the original gun laws
in the last century were put in place to
stop blacks from getting guns I mean
that's my understanding right and so I
think minorities being well armed is is
wonderful as long as they're responsible
gun owners some where where would you go
outside the the u.s. if if it came to
that anywhere zero so I would say
there's try three places off the top of
my head one is Bulgaria just given the
fact that we've both spent a lot of time
in Bulgaria so for this I don't know
both my fiancee and Mike's fiancee well
Polly is Bulgarian natalie is Bulgarian
ROG
she spent 20 years like 15 years there
yeah a long time so that's one Singapore
would be another one that would be a
just again Singapore
I've been two or three times now I think
you know you can't bring your guns you
can't bring your weapons there yeah I
haven't looked at Singapore in any kind
of real materially yeah I see you born
in Mexico like central Mexico setting up
there like an autonomous zone of your
own I really do I I think that you might
that's what we call a cartel I use that
word but I think you know you could do
well I mean look if you look around the
world right like there's no perfect
place like America on paper is the place
and that's why people that's another
thing you don't see millions of refugees
fleeing the United States right even in
the worst of times people flee their
countries to come here and so it is a
little bit ridiculous of me to talk
about like leaving the US but I I'm a
little bit worried and so I think what
we drive you leaving would it be a
safety thing or is it more of just like
a headache thing where regulation or
taxes or something like that
taxes are you know people talk about the
tax situation but at the u.s. is the
only effectively the only country in the
world where you're taxed on worldwide
income and so you don't see a lot of
Americans living in Singapore Dubai for
the tax benefits because they still pay
you as taxes right but you see lots of
like other nationalities living in these
countries and and so that's a real
that's a real pain in the butt but I I
don't see myself like giving up US
citizenship but I don't mind paying
taxes but that's that is an issue that
you cannot get away from that but I just
think ultimately I would just want to be
somewhere safe and civilized that like I
could you know raise a family and that's
that's there's lots of places for that
yeah I generally think of it as like
there's an overlap between a place that
is fairly safe mostly common sense
regulation government etc and also a
place where they just leave you alone
right next to Co is right
either like it's not safe but you can
make it safe with your own paramilitary
organization I seriously think I see you
as a as a warlord in Mexico like doing
quite well for yourself
so you know want nothing to do with that
literally nothing to do with that
what uh what types of things in a crypt
are you guys excited about that either
you're looking for companies in the
space or or you guys have recently
invested in that you think is exciting
Bitcoin I'll tell you that it's so funny
everybody assumes I'm a big XRP shell
and we love we love Ripple and we love
what XRP is doing but but you know we
own vastly more Bitcoin than any other
asset and we always have in our fund
Bitcoin is the Alpha and the Omega the
beginning in the end and there's lots of
other interesting things happening but
they haven't proven themselves yet so
layer one tokens are not hot right now
we've invested in a bunch of them
Algren is one we still have high hopes
for as well as lots of others but you
know everybody's right now is focused on
defy and I think defy is interesting but
it has a lot of flaws and a lot of
people are very nervous about putting
any real money into defy because it's
not it just isn't secure it's not stable
like it needs to mature also the rates
the sort of margin forming going on
right now is outlandish and Canon is not
sustainable and so we're very shy
gun-shy around getting involved that
kind of fad as well but there are coins
out there that really do like really
serve a purpose and I still think
there's a lot of innovation happening
around that an example is in Korea we
invested in Terra and we invested in
Terra in like 2018 I don't know if you
know them but they're uh they're uh
they're a stable coin in Korea and
they're expanding to other countries
that's used for e-commerce and so if you
go to an e-commerce site in Korea and
you pay with their stable coin you
actually end up getting like a five or
ten percent discount and stable coins
that don't have to be a hundred percent
backed by currency they do in the US you
have to have a dollar for every you know
dollar stable coin issued but in other
countries that isn't necessarily the
case so you get seniority and you get
growth in the rate the bigger your
economy of usage of this coin goes the
more senora Joran flay Shin you get they
can actually use some of
that inflation to pay back ecommerce
sites the e-commerce sites get paid one
to one and so it's his virtuous cycle
more more people use Tara and Korea to
pay for stuff because of the discount
and then it creates a bigger economy
which gives more money for them to give
back to e-commerce sites it's a
beautiful system and it's worked out
really well and and that's an example of
like just a wonderful like invention of
a coin that can work anywhere in the
world that doesn't require one-to-one
backing of a stable coin and so we see
stuff like that and we you know the
venture capitalist to me comes out you
asked me earlier about the the you know
we do venture or do we do trading I
didn't really answer but I'm a venture
capitalist and so I like doing venture
deals I like groups of people
entrepreneurs starting companies going
from zero to one
I like investing in that the long shot
we're one in ten pays off but half of
our team is purely trading and they're
you know they trade every day and they
do a really good job that they do exotic
derivative stuff they're buying they're
selling their shorting they're longing
it's just you know they I I understand
more of what they do then I let on but I
mean right now I'm not that ignorant of
it but like they are experts and I let
them run and they've you know they've
outperformed Bitcoin but like 30% last
year and that was fantastic and Bitcoin
had a good year so we do a little bit of
both but I my heart is always in the
venture to do startups and the
entrepreneurs starting something new
that's what I love yeah and it feels to
me like there's the combination of those
two things right so like you're one of
the only funds I know that kind of says
look we're gonna almost be like 5050
we're gonna do a bunch of trading and
look at the liquid stuff but we're also
gonna do there are other funds there's
other ones that do it but like the ones
that I've seen and maybe I just haven't
seen others like you but a lot of them
have like a hedge fund or a liquid fund
and then they'll do like a sidecar or
those somehow like carve out and
separate fund the illiquid Smith but it
sounds like you guys are doing
everything all in one fund we're doing
those two things we there's some stuff
we we don't do but those are the two
things we do and I think that it's it's
good for us right now yeah yeah the
other thing you talked about was a
define and the one thing for me is like
I was telling one of our partners that
it feels like people are building
technology they're not yet building
product
they're right it's a lot of things that
it works and like if you're somewhat
technical or you've got a lot of
persistence and kind of self motivation
you can figure it out you can use it to
your point people are a little scared
about putting really big dollars at play
there but yeah compare it to a product
like a block fire or a Robin Hood or you
know these other FinTech like true
products with slip you X's and things
like that it just feels like there's
something very different there do you
see the same thing or you little bit
more bullish on kind of the user
experiences and product side of it well
okay I disagree somewhat so first of all
there's people like Vinny lingam have
you ever had Vinny on your show but
before it's company a Civic and I I
don't think I'm saying something I
shouldn't say like he has a who I might
be mid he's working on some stuff that I
think fixes a lot of the problems in D
Phi but I'll leave it there in case I
don't know what's been announced um and
we're not investors and I used a friend
I have no financial interest in what
he's doing I'd like ty wish I did
but I think that decentralization is has
many many problems and I talk about our
first closing of our fund was our very
first closing was fifty million dollars
in XRP and it it was like literally two
seconds
to confirm the transaction and we paid
tens of cents I think it's 40 cents for
the transaction
it blows Bitcoin out of the water right
it blows anything in the world out of
the water other than maybe handing a bag
of money to somebody and you can't beat
that with Bitcoin and but bitcoin is
decentralized and there's reasons why
all of the problems with Bitcoin are
acceptable and if you know if you don't
know what those reasons are listen to
your podcast or read the Bitcoin
standard right but the problems of defy
it is the decentralized products there's
so many points of failure and so many
points of risk and and it's hard and
it's messy and it just it's too much
friction and so it keeps people away
those problems can be fixed and I think
people like Vinny are doing it now in
the meantime companies look like like
block Phi and other companies are doing
amazing things
helping people in the meantime in the
meantime might be 20 years right get a
lot of the same services and a much
safer and easier and quicker way and so
we support both yeah it comes to
actually moving our money we use
companies like walk by because when
you're moving trends and millions of
dollars you need to know exactly what's
going to happen to that money yeah is it
fair to say that defy is there
correlations or comparisons to like
early internet where things were hard
they were slow they were messy like I
said I'm gonna get overtime over
something got improved yeah it's like
homebrew stuff right and it's fun to do
and it kind of works sometimes and when
it does work you're happy but you know
you're dealing with money here and and I
think people just want to make sure that
they don't lose their money and so you
know it is what it is we are we're
investing in these companies but we are
not margin for it we're just not we're
not getting in that that could end badly
makes sense last question for you before
I do the the rapid-fire at the end
do you miss traditional venture
investing I do but I don't necessary
miss Silicon Valley Silicon Valley has
become less interesting as a place over
the last couple of years and I think
it'll cycle back and I'll be right back
there but I don't miss the the culture
because I think the culture has changed
but I do always love meeting
entrepreneurs and helping them end and
I'll always love that yeah that's
awesome I asked you questions to end
each episode first is what is the most
important book you've ever read you know
it's so funny
the Bitcoin standard has been formative
and the author is such a dick right I
mean he's just personally he's just he's
very intelligent but he's just he's I
personally do not love him but the
Bitcoin standard in my current sort of
life right now and in crypto is is a
book I mean you you really need to read
the wipe the Scotia white paper you need
to read the Bitcoin standard if you want
to really understand at a basic level
why bitcoin is important
longer term I think Guns Germs and Steel
I don't you've ever read that but that
is a book that was formative to me in my
younger years and I often go back to it
and and how I think about the world and
why things are the way they are and I'd
recommend everybody read that as well I
actually have Guns Germs and Steel on my
top five I always say Rich Dad Poor Dad
a thinking girl read sure it just made a
Babylon and then gunshots and steel but
you told me before we got on that white
fragility was the sold out on Amazon I
couldn't get my copy you it's funny you
said you see different things off there
than I'm just kidding
last questions more fun aliens believer
or non-believer I just read a book
called the last human I tweeted about it
I I don't I don't know where these books
I read I didn't just find it somebody
recommended it on Twitter so things I
bought it it was super good yeah and
it's a combination of interesting thesis
so one is there's a guy named Rama's nan
I'm actually looking at my bookshelf
right now he wrote a book called Nexus a
few years ago it was a it was a trilogy
and it was it was sort of popular it's a
very good book but it's about networked
minds and he was sort of the idea of
using different technologies to actually
network our minds and the way that I
think we all understand what that means
now the last human is about networked
minds but it's also about aliens and
what a galaxy might look for and I love
the book like I read a lot of nonfiction
but I reward myself often with a good
fiction book and the the math the math
says there are aliens out there and and
if there aren't you know it's uh well
it's probably a hell of a piece of
evidence of the existence of God but
yeah I think aliens huh I mean I I hope
in our lifetime we get to meet them
right so it would be kind of boring not
to write like you spend so much time and
glow in the universe yeah yeah I'm with
you you could ask me one question into a
finish up what's the one question that
you have do you secretly love XRP
because again in our private
conversations you talk about it very
bullish Lee and how much you you really
have put most of your assets or intend
to in it and I'm just wondering you know
what your real view on X are
he is so should have never asked you
this question let's you ask you this
look you asked yesterday like what you
asked your audience on Twitter like what
we're gonna talk about a lot of the XRP
guys came out and they said they really
want to talk about it and they know my
opinion on it I'm in love with XRP and I
think it serves a very useful and
important purpose I just want you on the
record saying what you think about XRP
so I mean Brad and I basically talked
about it but if you separate XRP and
ripple ripple as a software company that
wants to build better software for banks
no-brainer makes sense like venture
capital bet I'm jealous I didn't invest
in ripple in the seed round and make a
bunch of money with all the metrics
right so I suppose it's the ripple XRP
relationship very weird to me I've been
on record million times in saying like I
don't know what that is or was or
whatever that's not my job like it is
what it is and we are here today I think
that XRP in XRP well because you know
that look the XR PRV i look I I'm not my
respect to them they they don't [ __ ]
around so I'm not a I'm not going to
mince words but no I think the answer be
as a part of the ripple product meaning
like they use it inside the product I
understand why they do that and I see
the advantages inside the ripple
ecosystem what I don't understand I
think where I choose to not engage on
this RP side is I don't understand what
people are buying it speculating on
future price movements right like to me
if ripple is successful that doesn't
mean that x RP has to be successful and
I think Bitcoin now you're terrific
really suspect you know listen by the
way Bitcoin for sure like I've said a
million times it is the most binary
thing you could find it is either gonna
be worth you know millions of dollars a
coin or is gonna be worth basically
nothing what do you think could crush
what do you think it hurt Bitcoin the
most so can make it worth nothing
self-inflicted wound
like there's some there's some code
that's pushed that somehow does
something detrimental in a material way
I think that's like the most likely
thing I disagree I disagree with that
why what if the
US government declared it like seriously
declared a national security threat and
and did everything that could have shut
it up they could clearly kill the Fiat
on ramps and off ramps right I think
that's the biggest danger I think that
China and Russia would love that they
want to get off the US dollar so badly
and I think that what they would look at
and say is wait a second interesting
so you think bitcoin is so large now
that the US government cannot
effectively take it down anymore that's
really interesting thought well what I
think they can do is I think that they
can heavily discourage if not cut off
the United States citizens from using it
sure I said bait ownership do all I can
stuff what I think that was on a global
basis
Russia and China both have publicly
stated many times that the u.s. dollar
system is incredibly detrimental it's
expensive it's costly to them all that
kind of stuff yeah then you look at
places like you know Venezuela all these
places that are sanctioned they would
love nothing more than the u.s. to
openly say we don't like something and
then they all run and go use it and then
they can basically have like the u.s.
system of the world and then you have
like the non-us system of the world and
I recently saw two data points I thought
were really interesting I don't know how
much volumes gone through you one of
these so take it for what it is but in
Venezuela they are using B TCP B TCP
server whatever is called to allow
people to pay with Bitcoin for
government services so look you want
your driver's license nobody can get
another it just came out Marty Ben is
the one who highlighted this that I saw
I'm talking about it so he he basically
positioned it is like the Venezuelan
government is acquiring Bitcoin I don't
know if there's enough you know actual
transactions to like make that case but
the fact that they're willing to
understand that this is possible and
they're willing to actually allow people
to pay with Bitcoin to the government
but that's interesting the second thing
is I know for a fact the way you light
up when you talk about that quite like
your energy level just went through the
roof I love the I love watching you talk
about this this is what you look for in
entrepreneurs it's passionate about
whatever product there you know it's the
only piece of technology that I've ever
seen that kid that has the addressable
market of the world everyone yeah but
like literally it will touch seven
billion
people if it becomes like on the upper
most limit of what we think it can
become the other thing that I definitely
think is more likely than not is that
you me and everybody else is under
estimating how big it can get so if you
think of you know everyone always
compares us to like oh the 90 trillion
dollar monetary supply whatever
Mourad mohab the he record episode maybe
a year and a half ago now and he came in
he made an argument that bitcoins market
cap is not comparable just to the global
monetary supply at 90 trillion he
thought it was 150 trillion and how he
got there was a lot of the assets that
you or I own we own because we don't
want to hold cash because of inflation
so we'll buy you know a house our you
know whatever all this stuff right right
sure
and so instead just like uber was a
market expanding piece of technology and
it wasn't just against taxis it ended up
like some people own cars same thing
here where now all sudden maybe I don't
put my wealth in store value assets I
can actually put that in quantico
currency because it's a deflationary
type currency so I think that's
interesting but the other point is
there's number of countries that are now
putting national resources towards
mining and so nefarious actors like
North Korea are rumored to be doing it
right and that's how they're driving
some revenue but then if you look at
places like again Iran China at these
different countries it's just you're
getting to a point now where the world's
never had something that is truly not
manipulated and not controlled by
anybody and so I fear that the US every
time they've ever seen something like
that they just saw like nope if you go
like deep enough down the stack like you
can find the point of failure but if
there actually is something that has no
point of failure in terms of control or
ownership the countries that embrace it
first end up winning right it's is that
fighter like they get screwed right
because they end up being the ones
without any so I think that some of the
most interesting content we've had in
the last hour plus is in the last few
minutes you talk about Bitcoin like I
want more of it like I like the you
interview people and you're very good
interviewer and I'm I've interviewed a
lot of people so I understand what it
takes to do that but you it's just fun
listening to you can you talk like
you're a true believer I mean you're
like a Scientologist who you're you're
Tom Cruise jumping up and down on the
couch and I mean that in a positive I
mean it's funny but I also mean it like
fairly
positively like it's you you you believe
this crazy stuff and I do too but I will
tell you this I think that there are
three interesting coin models out there
I think there's a lot more like the
terror when I talked about but you've
got Bitcoin which is money I think you
and I agree on that and a lot of part of
your audience agrees on that a theory
I'm is the worldwide computer and it's
definitely interesting now ether may or
may not end up being that or somebody
else may be that but I think that's an
interesting model as well the third one
is I don't want to call it a banker coin
because the XRP army doesn't like that
but like what ripple is doing can
disrupt the banking system in a positive
way it can help them eventually move to
a Bitcoin world I think in a way that's
like very important and Bitcoin you know
in the Bitcoin scanner you talk a lot
about how you get around the issues of
this the the how slow the inexpensive
the Bitcoin network is you do it through
banks like in divisions banks well
you're going to need I mean yes you
could have banks but if they're not if
they're issuing artificial like fiat
basically like you know fractional
reserve type banking you're kind of back
in the old world and so I really think
XR PE has a chance to become like that
that coin that people use to actually
move the money around when they easy
stuff fast you need to be somewhat
centralized and the the downside of that
centralization I think it's less then
ultimately having very very powerful
banks control everything that there is
to know about there to control about
Bitcoin and yet do we do those two
things get mashed together in the sense
of let's say the u.s. issues a digital
dollar or like JPM coin comes out or
whatever do you think that that eats
into the potential that X or you can
have it definitely could I mean I mean
you know there's an argument that XRP
competes with tether more than Bitcoin
right and so if you look at how it's
being used now it's these cross-border
payments where it's there's a lot of
pain involved and it's really helped
MoneyGram you know with making these
cross-border payments faster and cheaper
so I look I think there's a long term
play for XRP we love it especially these
prices we look at the price of most
coins in in Bitcoin and SATs right we
look at we don't look at it as 230 bucks
or whatever it is right now we look at
how many SATs it is and we do that with
staying with XRP and XRP is I haven't
looked in the last couple hours but it's
hover around you know 2000 stats that's
very very cheap for xrp and so-and-so we
are more bullish on XRP than the
otherwise would be and we think over the
long run it's part of the ecosystem just
believe that but you're a good sport
about this because most Bitcoin
maximalist cannot stomach even having a
conversation beyond how great bitcoin is
and I think that you are somebody that's
helping bring this community together
instead of helping rip it apart and I
think that you're an important asset
because of that so I'm glad you do what
you do yeah listen I appreciate it I
appreciate you taking the time to do
this to be honest I was scared that you
were hanging out and Chazz and I was
never gonna get you on like you were
beginning to become the mayor of Chazz I
didn't want to go I could drive over
there I did want to go but just a little
bit afraid if you go you have to live in
it you just have to walk around with
your phone and just film I think it's
over now isn't it over I saw that there
like I don't know either yeah it's a
great marketing uh it's a great
marketing tool for uh for maybe some uh
you know rule of law also so much for
having me on yeah absolutely thank you
so much for doing we'll do it again in
the future all right